500th episode and I'm party like it's
oh if it's 1999 I'd better get in a line
for the premiere of Phantom Menace I
just know it's gonna be awesome
first your comments actually only your
comments this week I only made it to 100
episodes because of your support
seriously you're all insane Firefly and
freaks and geeks got cancelled after one
season but I'm still on the air what are
you people thinking so action real
person guy yeah asked if I've seen
project Almanac no a future version of
me travel back in time to warn me that
it wasn't very good Alex Hirsch asks how
was Birdman it was great now I hope they
make a series of blockbusters superhero
movies about the character his motto can
be justice is a thing with feathers ah
that'd be sick I don't think that's the
takeaway the director intended for me to
have but there ain't no Roy Everett
agrees with me about the awfulness of
the Smurfs movies imposes the age-old
question how does a smurf race
repopulate itself if there's only one
Smurfette Roy I'm afraid that fanfic
authors have proposed a hundred thousand
different answers to your question each
one more unsavory than the last
sweet captain 77 asks what kind of
fanfic interests me you know I just
looked at a fanfic that roofs on The
Simpsons it takes the same premise of
characters buddy it sets him in New
England and it isn't funny it's called
Family Guy oh yeah I said it so I
invited you all the right angry nerd
fanfic as long as it wasn't dirty
Andrew royal who apparently thinks I'm
too optimistic about episode 7 wrote a
very short story about me
once the camera stopped JJ Abrams
switched off the power putting his bald
yes bot into standby mode the ends
Hey don't forget about the part where
the bald yes but tells Abrams that the
ending to loss made perfect sense and it
was totally satisfying cap crunch 45
asked if I caught Game of Thrones in
IMAX
ah I missed it still kicking myself you
know I wish they release more classic TV
and IMAX like the candy conveyor belt
episode of I Love Lucy sneak to attack
asked what I thought of Tron Legacy not
as good as the original but fine JJ
asked angry nerd have you seen Mortal
Kombat rebirth yes better than any
theatrically released Mortal Kombat from
Bach reviews I'm curious if you've seen
a show called Steven universe I love
Steven universe Lord odda science do you
have an opinion on lego bionicle no Josh
Brubaker asks is there a possibility of
a calendar showing off the best angry
nerd cosplays well sure but instead of a
monthly pinup wouldn't you rather have a
nitpick add a calendar January 1st
explosions in space don't make a sound
square root of forty seven squared asks
if The Magic the Gathering cards
scattered on my desk are always there
yes but someone keeps stealing my rares
eight burning eyes uber a-- is watching
all of you now for my Jupiter ascending
ran Adrian writes who is this annoying
fat Oh Adrian that's no way to talk
about Channing Tatum see this movie was
clearly a bad career choice for him but
yeah talking about me that's impossible
I'm not annoying John writes it will be
funny to hear me curse a lot in a video
about my most hated movie slash show
slash comic maybe I should do an episode
long rant about that Lord Michael Bay
that God mother worthless pile of
directs movies like a scruffy-looking
muhurta
he's a farming explosion his movies are
pure
rady top with with a side of fetid
disease monkey and i poke his get caught
in a god threat Kamala Khan suggests
that my new animated sidekick Gary the
wisecracking honey badger could join The
Avengers maybe be their Rocket Raccoon
well I'll tell you one thing Kamala
Marvel DC would probably spring for the
effects required to render him in
high-res splendor not like these cheapo
bits I currently work for Christopher de
Mariano's has asked me about a dozen
times to rant about the new season of
Pokemon I'm flattered you're so
interested in my opinion but I'm sorry
Chris it's just not gonna happen I have
no strong feelings about the cartoon
please don't attack me with volt tackle
Jacobs sweater wonders what I think of
the Teen Wolf series hey it's the best
monster soap opera since Ron Perlman's
Beauty and the Beast and you can quote
me on that
hey thanks again to all of you for
watching seriously and please keep the
comments coming I really do try to
answer as many as I can what topics
would you like to see me tackle on
upcoming episodes let me know subscribe
to the wire channel and click over there
to watch my other rants ahh it feels
like it was only yesterday we couldn't
be even imagined of Smurfs movie back in
there when I was starting or that there
would be five transformer movies or they
I'd be tired of comic book movies how
did it ever get to that point